мій номер та естр та вид крито активності
центру ставок едіку рубці від райдужку
людина аналізу вати , не що він і
спокої багатих українців
джейм володе та президент україни Петра
порошенка
значить у нього з льону ділянка перерахунок
і добу арафа кучно 4 віктор і в казані
ці землі та вказівки області а також
мазепі віктора в одному з центральних
районів Києва
порушено копри 2 вже на посаді президента
до президентства вин купаємо ділянку по
оку києва та в одеській області за
голом близькому 8 гектарів у його дружини
марини нічого не травня про прем'єр-міністра
яценюка та його дружини торезе і також
видно з реєстром на мої землі не
будемо kill не квартир а джеду бази
даних вниз він вийшов борідкою ми нових 3
смолоскип купа рація рацію на руку мастю
опинялося до 1240 року іванівці та ресторани
потрапив та наповнення мереж інформацію
фактично navi видобувається там ще
заздрити вирішують у класі їм на руку
мастю виглядає там купив ночі продажів
так не запарив до 2012 року на російську
тиша по парових націях їх плану ці
пари вістку цифрової форми з роком
дисп одягаєте активісти за майном
корупціонерів стануть сидиш трохи
владою президентів тягача януковича
за рай з true видно що його ми знаємо
ж гирі квартира гаражу києву за ростова
на судом а пупер аддонів державну
владність активісти автомайдану вже
сир з пасторі гаїті зажити am
українських політиків та чиновників з
висоти по ташеновому польоту за допомогу
ядро ніл про росіян не пляшка за
високому та парку на травень місяця регулярно
інформуйте ви мочитеся на рази одну з
головних ви міг євромайдану про відносини
влада вигляд корупціонерів поважати анту
мононитки не виконано квітки ратями
нових реєстрів роботи в них краще
більше ми будемо видаліли продовжила ти б
ти підкоримо нитки доль МВС і прокуратура
видам з представлять і
б на живучи чол з ще
малі роду ніж український реєстр
влада таких члени дошку на чи
активістів же ти пара вказувати на вигляд
повинность привид нас проблема за новим
даних відпочиває він як про колонію центрі
ставок ідейку рубці чисто на арку
чиновникам
буду складні шик він верстувати хабаре у
землі квартири і буде до